السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته
طبعا حضراتكو انا بس هادخل في التفاصيل مباشرة
عشان خاطر احنا ما بنجيبش معلومات زي ما بيقولو كده ايه
بنتفصحن او بنجيب معلومات من الهواء
انا حطيت الصعيد بتاع الاوفر هايد بتاع الدولة بتاع
الدولة الهولندية
ايه اللي قالته
وازاي الحلول الموجودة بالنسبة ليهم بيفكرو فيها
ان هم يحلو مشكلة اللاجئين
او اللي هو التوافد اللاجئين بالعدد ده لهولندا
ومن ضمن الامور
مكتوب على ااا ان دخلت اللي هو اللي بيدخلو اللاجئين
على اساس بيحكو حكايات كلها كاذبة عشان يحصلو على اللجوء
وفي بعض اللاجئين بيقولو عليهم اللي هم اللي مانس سموكلا
اللي هو
تجارة البشر زي ما بيقولو اللي هو التجارة في البشر
وما بين الدول وبعضها
او اللي بيجيب الناس اللي بتشتغل في التهريب
وحتى اتكلمو عن ان
يتكلمو ازاي مع هؤلاء ايطاليا واليونان
فازاي يحدو من الهجرة دي
وبرضه بعد الدول ال2 حتى لو الامر وصل للترحيل المباشر
في كمان موجود على السايت حاجات بيحاولو يعملوها
ان هم يحاولو
يعملو تصالح مع بعض الدول الموجود فيها الحروب
عشان يعملو مشروعات ليهم
ويحاولو يقللو نسبة الهجرة
واللاجئين الموجودين على ارض الدول دي
يرجعو يشتغلو فيها
بالتعاون ما بين
الحكومات وبعضها
حتى بيفكرو كمان
في موضوع حكاية اللي اللي نزلوه
لم الشمل دوت لخمستاشر شهر
وفي ناس كتير قوي بقت ما بين
ااا زي ما بيقولو كده خايفة
خمستاشر شهر بيبدا من امتى
وهل في ناس هينطبق عليها القانون ده ولا لا
والناس الجداد هيتعمل معاهم ايه
كتير جدا من الاسئلة الناس ابتدت تسالها العاطل بقى مع
الكويس والوحش بقو بيغطو على بعض
اللي بيقدم على لم الشمل
بقى بيقدم
مش مشكلة مش فارقة معاه هو احق او غير احق ظلمو ناس
لكن خلينا نكون مع بعضنا
صراحة ان في ظلم في القرار
وهيكون في الفترة اللي جاية
في قوة في اتخاذ القرارات
وانا يعني انا والله ما بقول الكلام ده عشان اخوف حد
لكن الكلام ده لازم الناس تكون متهيئة له ومستعدة له
احنا بايدينا
نقدر نغير قانون لو ايدينا ايد 1
لو القانون متعسف
وبايدينا نقدر نخليهم يدوسو على دماغنا اتمنى
ان الرسالة تكون وصلت للناس اتمنى تدخلو التقرو
تشوفو التفكير بتاع الدولة
ناويين على ايه ونفسهم يعملو ايه تابعني